the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so we're going to continue to look
at stuff in space so we've been working
with triple integrals and seeing how to
set them up in all sorts of coordinate
systems and the next topic will be
looking at our vector fields in space
and so in particular we'll be learning
about flux and work so just for a change
will be starting with flux first and
we'll do work actually after
Thanksgiving so just remind you well a
vector field in space is just the same
thing as in the plane at every point you
have a vector field so at every point
you have a vector and the components of
this vector depends on the coordinates
XY and Z okay so
so let's say the components might be PQR
or your favorite letters where each of
these things is a function of the
coordinates X Y Z and
so you know you've seen that in the
plane it's already pretty hard to the
power vector field so usually in space
we want really try to house okay but
it's still useful to try to have a
general idea for what the vectors and
they are doing you know whether they're
all going the same direction whether
they're maybe all vertical or horizontal
pointing away from the origin two words
it things like that but we want
generally speaking we want to really
bother with try to draw a picture
because that's going to be quite hard
just to give you examples well the same
kind of examples as the plane you can
think of fast fields so for example the
gravitational attraction of a solid mass
at the origin on a mass m at let's call
this mass Big M at the point X Y Z that
would be given by a vector field that
points towards the origin and whose
magnitude is inversely proportional to
the square of a distance from the origin
okay so
such a field would be directed towards
origin towards the origin and its
magnitude would be of the order of a
constant of a whole squared we're always
the distance from the origin so the
picture are they really if I really
wanted to draw a picture would be
everywhere it's a field that points
towards the origin and if I'm far away
then it gets smaller and of course I'm
not going to try to draw all these
vectors in there okay so if I wanted to
give a formula for that Oh
so formula for that might be something
of a firm - C times X Y Z of a whole
cubed let's see well the direction of
this vector so this vector is
proportional to negative X Y Z X Y Z is
the vector that goes from the origin to
your point the negative goes towards the
origin when the magnitude of this guy
well negative X comma Y comma Z is just
distance from the origin let's hope so
the magnitude of this thing is one of
our whole squared times some constant
vector okay so that would be an example
of a vector field that comes up in
physics well other examples would be
electric fields actually if you look at
the electric field generated by a
charged particle at the origin it's
given by exactly the same kind of
formula and there's magnetic fields and
so on another example comes from
velocity fields so if you have a fluid
flow for example if you want to study
you know wind patterns in the atmosphere
well when most of the time is kind of
horizontal but maybe it depends on the
altitude you know that at high altitude
you have jet streams when velocity is
not the same at all altitudes and you
know just to give you more examples well
in math we've seen that the gradient of
a function of three variables gives you
a vector field you have a function U of
X Y Z then it's gradient field has just
components u sub X u sub y and u sub Z
and of course the cases are not
exclusive are not mutually exclusive
right for example the electric field or
gravitational field
given by the gradient of the
gravitational or electric potential so
you know these are not like different
cases there's overlap okay so anyway
hopefully you're kind of convinced that
you should learn about gradient about
vector fields what are we going to do
with them well let's start with flux so
remember not so long ago we've looked at
flux of a 2-dimensional vector field for
a curve so we had a curve in the plane
and we had a vector field and we looked
at the component of a vector field in
the direction that was normal to the
curve so we formed the flux integral
that was a line integral F dot NDS and
that measured how much the vector field
was going across the curve so if you
were thinking of a velocity field that
would measure how much fluid is passing
through the curve in unit time okay now
let's save it we're in space well we
can't really think of flux as a line
integral because if you have you know a
curve in space and say that you have
wind or something like that
you can't really ask how much air is
flowing through the curve C to have a
flow for something you need actually a
surface if you have a net maybe then you
can ask how much stuff is passing
through that surface so there's going to
be a big difference here in the
conventional case flux will be measured
for a surface
and so it will be actually a surface
integral not a line integral anymore so
that means we'll be integrating will be
summing over all the pieces of a surface
in space because a surface is a
two-dimensional object that will end up
being a double integral but of course
we'll have to set it up properly because
the surfaces in space so probably will
have XY and Z to deal with at the same
time and we'll have to somehow get rid
of one variable so that we can set up
and evaluate a double integral so
conceptually it's very similar to line
integrals just you know in the line
integral in the plane you had two
variables that you reduced to one by
figuring out what the curve is and here
you'll have three variables which will
reduce to two by figuring out what the
surface is
okay so let me give you the definition
of flux in 3d so let's say that we have
a vector field and as a surface in space
so let me draw some kind of picture you
know I have my surface and I have my
vector field F well at every point it
changes with a point well I want to
figure out how much my vector field is
going in cause that surface so that
means actually I want to figure out the
normal component of my vector field okay
so I will use as in the plane case the
unit normal vector to s so you know I
take my point on the surface and I build
a unit vector but standing on it
perpendicularly now well we have to
decide actually which way it's standing
right we can build our normal vector to
go this way or to go the other way
around there's two choices basically
whenever you want to set up a flux
integral you have to decide you have to
choose one side of the surface and you
will count positively what flows towards
that side negatively what flows towards
the other side so there's two choices
for n we need to choose a side of the
surface so in the case of curves see
actually we made that choice by deciding
that because we were going along some
Junction on the curve we could define we
could choose one side by saying let's
rotate clockwise from the tangent vector
and in a way what we were doing it was
really it was a recipe to choose for us
one of the two sides so here we don't
have a notion of
orienting the surface other than by
precisely choosing one of the two
possible normal vectors so in fact this
is called choosing an orientation of the
surface when you're saying that you're
re-entering the surface that when it
means you're deciding which side is
which it's let's call an orientation now
there's no set convention that will work
forever but the usual traditional
settings would be to take your normal
vector pointing maybe out of a solid
region because then you'll be looking at
flux that's coming out of that region of
space if you have a surface that's not
like closed or anything but maybe you
will want the flux going up out sorry up
for the region or there's various
conventions so you know concretely on
problems it will either say which choice
you have to make or you get to choose
which one you want to make and of course
if you choose the other one when the
sign becomes the opposite so now once
we've made a choice then we can define
the flux integral it will just be the
double integral over the surface of f
dot n D s so now I'm using a big Dia's
that stands for the surface area element
on this surface I'm using ds5 evan da
because i was I still want to think of
da as maybe the area in one of the
coordinate planes like the one we had in
double integrals you'll see later where
this comes in but conceptually it's very
similar
okay so completely what this means is
you know I take I cut my surface into
little pieces each of them has area
Delta s and for each piece I take my
vector field I take my normal vector I
dot them and I multiply by this surface
area and I sum all these things together
that's what the double integral means
so in particular an easy case where you
know you can get away without computing
anything is of course if your vector
field is tangent to the surface because
then you know that there's no flux I
mean flux is going to be zero because
nothing passes for the surface otherwise
well we have to figure out how to
compute these things so that's what we
are going to learn now well maybe I
should box this formula i i've noticed
that some of you seem to like it when i
box the important formula so okay by the
way a piece of notation before i move on
so sometimes you'll also see if notation
vector ideas
what is vector D as vector D s is this
guy NDS put together
okay so vector D s is a vector which
points perpendicular to the surface and
whose length corresponds to the surface
element and the reason for having this
shortcut notation well not only is not
only laziness you know like saving 1/n
but it's because this guy is very often
easier to compute than it is to set up
and indeed separately actually if you
remember in the plane we've seen that
vector n little DS can be written
directly as dy comma negative DX that
was easier than finding N and D s
separately and here the same is going to
be true in many cases
okay so well so just sigh any questions
before we do examples no okay let's do
examples so the first example for today
we're going to look at the flux of the
vector field X I plus YJ plus ZK for the
sphere of radius a centered at the
origin okay so what does the picture
look like
we have a sphere of radius-a I have my
vector field well X comma Y comma Z see
that's a vector field that's equal to
the vector from the origin to the point
where I am so it's pointing radially
away from the origin so my vector field
is really sticking out everywhere
away from the origin now I have to find
the normal vector to the sphere if I
want to set up double integral over the
sphere of F that vector da so if you
want F that NDS
so what does the normal vector to the
sphere look like well depends of course
with I choose it pointing out or in
let's say I'm choosing it pointing it
out then it will be sticking straight
out of a sphere as well so hopefully you
can see that if I take a normal vector
to the sphere it's actually pointing
radially out away from the origin so in
fact our vector field and our normal
vector are parallel to each other okay
let's think a bit more about what the
normal vector looks like so I say it's
sticking straight out it's proportional
to this vector field so maybe I should
start by writing X Y Z because that's
the vector that goes from the origin to
my point so it points radially away from
the origin now there's a small problem
with that it's not a unit vector so what
is its length well its length is square
root of X square plus y square plus Z
squared but if I'm on the sphere then
that length is just equal to a because
distance from the origin is a so in fact
I get my normal vector by scaling this
guy down
Fecteau of a okay and let me write down
just in case you're still unsure this is
unit because square root of x square
plus y squared plus Z squared is equal
to a on the sphere okay any questions
about this now looks okay I see a lot of
blank faces that physics test must have
been hard
yes I could have put a hole but I want
to emphasize the fact that here is going
to be a constant see I mean who has this
connotation of being a variable that I
will need to learn maybe integrate over
or do something with and yes it would be
correct to put whole but I really want
to put you know then later will want to
replace it by its actual value which is
a number then the number is a it's not
going to actually change from point to
point for example if this was the unit
sphere then I would just put you know
XYZ I wouldn't divide by anything okay
so now let's figure out F that n let's
do things one at a time well F and n are
parallel to each other so f dot n the
normal component of F is actually equal
to the length of F well times the length
of n if you want but that's going to be
one since F and n are parallel to each
other and what's the magnitude of F if
I'm on the sphere well negative F in
general is square root of x square plus
y square plus Z squared on the sphere
it's going to be a if you have a way to
do it if you don't want to thank
geometrically like that is to just do
the dot product XYZ dotted with X over a
way over a zero a you will get X square
plus y square plus this
well / a that will simplify to a because
we on the sphere so see we're already
actually using here the relation between
X Y & Z we are not letting X Y & Z be
completely arbitrary but the slogan is
everything happens on the surface where
we're doing the integral we are not
looking at anything inside or outside
we'll just on the surface
so now what do I do with that
well I've turned my integral into the
double integral of a DS and a is just a
constant so I'm very lucky here I can
just say well this will be a times the
double integral of DS and of course
someday I'll have to learn how to tackle
that beast but for now I don't actually
need to because the double integral of D
s just means I'm summing the area of
each little piece of the sphere I'm just
going to get the total area of the
sphere which I know to be 4 PI a squared
ok so this guy here is going to be the
area of s so I know that to be 4 PI a
squared so I will get 4 PI a cubed ok so
that one was relatively painless that
was too easy
so let's do a second example with the
same sphere but now my vector field is
going to be just Z times K well let me
give it a different name let me call it
H instead of F or something like that
just so that it's not called F anymore
ok well the initial part of the setup is
still the same the normal vector is
still the same what changes is of course
my vector field is no longer sticking
straight out so I can't use this easy
geometric argument looks like I will
have to compute F dot N and then figure
out how to integrate that with Diaz so
let's do that so
we still have that n is X Y Z divided by
a so that tells us that H dot n will be
well zero zero Z that X Y Z over a looks
like a we'll be left with Z squared over
a sorry
so H dot n is Z squared over a so the
double integral for flux now becomes
double integral on the sphere of Z
squared of our a DS well we can take out
the 1 over a that's fine but looks like
we'll have actually to integrate Z
squared on the surface of the sphere so
how do we do that well we have to figure
out what is d s in terms of our favorite
set of two variables that we'll use to
integrate now what's the best way to
figure out where you are on the sphere
well you could try to use maybe theta
and Z you know if you know how high you
are and where you are around in
principle you know where you're on the
sphere but since then since the nodal
coordinates we've actually learned about
something much much more interesting
namely spherical coordinates it looks
like longitude latitude is the way to go
when trying to figure out where you are
on the sphere so we're going to use 3
and theta and of course we have to
figure out how to express D's in terms
of DC and D theta well if you were
paying really really close attention
last time then you'll notice that we've
actually already done that ok so last
time we've seen that if I have a sphere
of radius-a
and I take a little piece of it that
corresponds to small changes in fee and
theta then we said that well we argued
that this side here the one that's going
east west was a piece of a circle of
radius this east-west circle has a
radius a sign fee because that's our so
let's sigh this a sine Phi Delta Theta
and the side that goes enough south is a
piece of a circle of radius a cause
going to angle Delta Phi so it's a Delta
V and so just to get to the answer we
got D as equals a squared sine Phi D Phi
D theta okay so when we set up a surface
integral on the surface of a sphere most
likely we'll be using C and theta as our
two variables of integration and D s
will become this now it's okay to think
of em as spherical coordinates but I'd
like to encourage you not to think of
them as spherical coordinates spherical
coordinates are a way of describing
points in space in terms of three
variables here it's more like we're
parameterizing the sphere we're finding
a parametric equation for the sphere
using two variables V and theta which
happen to be part of a spherical
coordinate system but see there's no
hole involved in here I'm not using any
row ever and I'm not going to in this
calculation I have two variables Phi and
theta that's it
okay it's basically in the same way as
you know when you parameterize a line
integral in the circle we use theta as
the parameter variable and we never we
never think about our okay so that being
said well we're going to use three and
theta we know what DS is we still need
to figure out what Z is well so where we
want to think a tiny bit about spherical
coordinates again and we'll know that Z
well is just a cosine fee okay in case
you don't quite see it let me also
diagram you know that fee is the angle
down from the positive z axis this
distance is a so this distance here is a
cosine fee okay so now I have everything
I need to compute my double integral Z
squared over a DL will become a double
integral of so Z square becomes a
squared cosine fee cosine square Phi
sine over a times D s becomes a squared
sine Phi D Phi D theta now I need to set
up bounds well whatever bounds she goes
all the way from 0 to PI because we go
all the way from the North Pole to the
South Pole and theta goes from 0 to 2 pi
and of course I can get rid of some a
sin valent take them out okay so let's
look actually at what number we get so
first of all we can take out all those s
we get an a cubed okay
second so in the inner integral we are
integrating cosine square Phi sine Phi
DV I claim that integrates two cosine
cubed up to some factor and that factor
should be negative one third if you look
at cosine cube fee and you take its
derivative you will get that guy with a
negative 3 in front between 0 and PI and
while integrating over theta will just
multiply things by 2 pi so let me add a
2 pi in front okay now if I evaluate
this guy between 0 and PI while at PI
cosine cube is negative 1 at 0 its 1 I
will get actually 2/3 out of this so I
end up with 4/3 PI a cubed ok so I don't
write very much but trying to save
blackbaud space
yes yes that's a very natural question
that seems that looks a lot like
somebody we know like the volume of the
sphere and ultimately it will be wait
until next class when we talk about the
divergence theorem okay
so yeah I mean the question was is this
related to the volume of a sphere and
ultimately it is but for now it's just
you know some coincidence yes
so is there okay so the question is is
far away to do with M DX plus n dy plus
stuff like that the answer is
unfortunately no because it's not a line
integral it's a surface integral so we
need to have two variables in there so
in a way you'll end up with things like
you know some DX dy s maybe and so on I
mean it's not practical to do it
directly that way because you'd have
then to compute J columns to switch from
DX dy to something else so we are going
to see various ways of computing it
unfortunately it's not quite as simple
as with line integrals but it's not much
harder it's the same spirit we just use
two variables and we set up everything
in terms of these two variables okay any
other questions No
okay
okay by the way just some food for
thought now never mind okay so
conclusion of looking at these two
examples is that sometimes we can use
geometry in the first example we didn't
actually have to compute an integral but
most of the time we need to learn how to
set up double integrals so use geometry
or you need to set up the double
integral over the surface and so we're
going to learn how to do that in general
so as I said we need to have two
parameters on the surface and Express
arriving in terms of these so let's look
at various examples so we need to see
you know various situations where we can
do things well let's start with an easy
one let's call that number zero actually
you know say that my surface s is a
horizontal plane so say is equals ay
okay so when I say a physanto plane it
doesn't have to be the entire horizontal
plane you know it could be a small piece
of it it could even be to take you you
know maybe an ellipse in there or
triangle in there or something like that
what you have to recognize is my surface
it's a piece of just a flat plane so I
should not worry too much about what
part of the plane it is well it will
become important when I set up bounds
for integration but when it comes to
looking for the normal vector I can rest
assured that the normal vector to a
horizontal plane is just vertical okay
so it's going to be either K or negative
K depending on whether I've chosen two
oriented pointing up or down and which
one I choose might depend on what I'm
going to try to do
so the normal vector is just sticking
straight up or straight down
now what about des well it's going to be
just the a higher element in a
horizontal plane just looks like it
should be DX dy I mean if I'm moving in
a horizontal plane to know where I am I
should know x and y so the S will be DX
dy so if I play the game that way you
know I have my vector field F I do F
that and that just gives me the Z
component which might involve XY and z
X&Y I'm very happy with they will stand
us as my variables
whenever I see Z what I want to get rid
of it but that's easy because Z is just
equal to a so I just plug that value and
I'm left with only x and y and I'm
integrating that DX dy so it's actually
ending up being just a usual double
integral in XY coordinates and of course
once it's set up anything is fair game
you know I might want to switch to polar
coordinates or something like that I can
set it up DX dy or dy DX all the usual
stuff applies okay but for the initial
setup we are just going to use these and
express everything in terms of X and y
actually a small variation on that well
let's say that we take vertical planes
that are parallel to say maybe the
blackboard plane so parallel to the Y Z
plane so that might be something like x
equals some constant well what would I
do then it will be pretty much the same
the normal vector to this guy would be
sticking straight out towards me or away
from me let's say and having it come to
the front well so the normal vector
would be plus minus I and the variables
that I would be using to find out my
position on this guy would be
y&z so in terms of those the surface
element is just dy DZ
similarly for planes parallel to the XZ
plane using well I mean so you can
figure that one out okay so you know
these are somehow the easiest ones
because those we already know how to
compute without too much trouble what if
it's a more complicated plane well we'll
come back to that next time let's
explore some other situations first okay
number one on the list after number zero
well let's say that I gave you a sphere
of radius a centered at the origin or
maybe just a half of that sphere or some
portion of it well we've already seen
how to do things namely we'll be saying
the normal vector is X Y Z over a well
plus or minus depending on whether we
wanted pointing in or out and the S will
be a squared sine Phi D Phi D theta so
in fact we will express everything in
terms of Phi and theta so if I wanted to
I could tell you what our formulas for
XYZ in terms of Phi and theta you know
them but it's actually better to wait a
little bit you know it's better to do f
dot n because f is also going to have a
bunch of X's YS and Z's and if there's
any kind of symmetry to the problem then
you might end up with things like X
square plus y square plus Z squared or
things that have more symmetry that are
easier to express in terms of Z and
theta so the advice would be you know
first do a dot product with F and then
see what you get and then turn it into
three and theta okay so that's
when we've seen let's say that I have so
it's a close cousin let's say you have a
cylinder of radius a centered on the z
axis okay so what does that look like
and when I say again when I say a
cylinder it could be you know a piece of
cylinder so first of all what does a
normal vector to a cylinder look like
well it's sticking straight out but
sticking straight out in a slightly
different way from what happens with the
sphere see the sides of a cylinder are
vertical so if you imagine you know you
have this big cylindrical pipe in front
of you hopefully you can see that the
normal vector is going to always be
horizontal it's taking straight out in
the horizontal directions it doesn't
have any Z component so the normal
vector I claim the normal vector of a
cylinder see if you have a point here at
XYZ well it will be pointing straight
out away from the central axis so my
normal vector well if I'm taking it to
point outwards will be going straight
away from the central axis that means
you know if I look at it from above
maybe it's easiest if I look at it from
above look at X Y so then my cylinder
looks like a circle and the normal
vector just points straight out see it's
the same situation as when we had a
circle in the 2d case the normal vector
for that is just going to be X Y and 0
in the Z component well plus minus
depending on whether you want it
sticking in or out
Oh
it's fixed
okay so we stayed on our cylinder normal
vector is plus minus XY 0 over a what
about the surface element so before we
ask that actually maybe we should first
figure out what coordinates are we going
to use to locate ourselves in a cylinder
well yes we probably want to use part of
the cylindrical coordinates except for
well we don't want to R because R
doesn't change it's not variable here
indeed you know you probably want to use
Z to tell how high you are and theta to
tell you where you are around so D s
should be in terms of DZ D theta now
what's the what's the constant well
let's look at the small piece of our
cylinder corresponding to a small angle
Delta Theta and a small height Delta Z
well the height as I said is going to be
Delta Z what about the width it's going
to be a piece of a circle of radius a
correspond to the angle Delta Theta so
this side will be a Delta Theta so Delta
s is a Delta Theta Delta Z so D s is
just a DZ D theta or D theta DZ doesn't
matter which way you do it okay and so
when we set up the flux integral we'll
take first with dot product of F with
this normal vector then we'll stick in
this D s and then of course we'll get
rid of any X and Y's that are left by
expressing them in terms of theta maybe
X becomes a cosine theta Y becomes a
sine theta okay so this various formulas
you should try to remember them because
they're really useful so for the sphere
for the cylinder hopefully those for the
planes you kind of know already
intuitively okay what about marginal
surfaces you know not everything in life
is made out of cylinders and spheres
just you know and it's a good tie but so
let's look at a marginal kind of surface
let's say give you the graph of a
function Z equals f of X Y so this guy
is nothing to do with the integrand it's
not what we are integrating we are just
integrating a vector field that has
nothing to do with that this is how I
want to describe the surface on which I
will be integrating okay so my surface
is given by Z is a function of X Y well
I would need to tell you what n is and
what D s is and that's going to be
slightly annoying I mean actually I
don't want to tell them separately
because you see that pretty hard so
instead I'm going to tell you that in
this case well let's see what variables
do we want so I'm going to tell you a
formula for NDS okay
but so what variables do we want to
express this in terms of well most
likely X&Y because we know how to
express Z in terms of X and Y so you
know this is an invitation to get rid of
any Z that might be left and set
everything up so I think up in terms of
DX dy so the formula that we are going
to see I think we are going to see the
details of why it works tomorrow is that
you can take negative partial F partial
X negative partial F partial y one dxdy
plus/minus depending on which way you
want it to go so if you really want to
know what is DS well D s is the
magnitude of this vector times DX dy see
there will be a square root and some
squares and some stuff
what's a normal vector well you take
this vector and you scale it down to
unit length okay so just to emphasize it
this guy here is not N and this guy here
is not D s each of them is more
complicated than that but the
combination somehow simplifies nicely
and let's good news files
so now concretely the one way you can
think about it is this tells you how to
reduce things to an integral of x and y
and of course you will have to figure
out whatever bounds on X & Y so that
means you will need to know what does
the shadow of your surface look like in
the XY plane so then to set up bounds on
whatever you will get the X dy well of
course you can switch to dy DX or
anything you like but you will need to
look at the shadow of s in the XY plane
but only do that after you've gotten rid
of all the Z right when you know you're
a busy when you can figure out what are
the bounds for X and y ok any questions
about that yes
Oh for the cylinder okay so let me
explain quickly how I get a normal
vector of a cylinder so if you if you
know what a cylinder looks like you
probably can see that the normal vector
sticks straight out of it
horizontally so that means the Z
component of n is going to be zero okay
and then the XY components you get by
looking at it from a booth wait wait
wait one last thing I want to say okay
so what about the geometric
interpretation and how to prove it well
if your vector field F is a velocity
field then the flux is the amount of
matter that crosses the surface but that
is for s per unit time and the way that
you would prove it would be similar to
the picture that I draw when we did in
the plane namely you would consider a
small element of the surface Delta s and
you would try to figure out what's the
stuff that flows for it in a second well
it's the stuff that lives in a small box
whose side well whose base is that piece
of surface and whose other side is given
by the vector field and then the volume
of that is given by base times height
and the height is f dot n okay so it's
the same argument as what we saw in the
plane okay so next time we'll see more
formulas will first see how to prove
this more ways to do it more examples
and then we'll get to the divergence
theorem